[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit jana
pareigis schönen guten abend und
herzlich willkommen zu knapp 20 minuten
nachrichten mit sport mit norbert
lehmann junior von und natürlich den
wichtigsten themen heute
abkehr von der neutralität finnland will
nato mitglied werben russland spricht
von einer bedrohung
weniger gas aus russland putin setzt
energie als waffe ein sack minister hahn
beck sieht aber noch keinen grund für
alarm
und möglicher anschlag auf schule
verhindert bei einem 16-jährigen essen
werden waffen und rechtsextremes
material gefunden
der norden europas zieht konsequenzen
aus dem ukraine krieg während schweden
noch überlegt hat sich finnland
stadtspitze heute offiziell für einen
schnellen nato beitritt ausgesprochen
das parlament in helsinki könnte schon
sehr bald zustimmen ein grundlegendes
umdenken denn finnland nach
jahrzehntelanger neutralität militär
strategisch hätte der schritt große
folgen die nato grenze zu russland würde
1300 kilometer länger und sich auf einen
schlag verdoppeln
dazu kommt finnlands gut ausgerüstete
armee moskau nennt den möglichen
beitritt eine bedrohung heike kruse
berichtet
eine internationale frühjahrs
militärübung in finnland obwohl das land
noch nicht nato mitglied ist zieht man
seit jahren gemeinsam ins manöver nur
5,5 millionen einwohner hat finnland
aber fast 900.000 soldaten und
reservisten den apotheken wir haben über
all die jahrzehnte ein gewisses niveau
aufrechterhalten während die übrigen
europäischen länder überlegt haben sich
auf krisenbewältigung zu konzentrieren
bei uns dagegen stand immer die
nationale verteidigung im mittelpunkt
die niveaus kümmert eine
nato-mitgliedschaft finnlands scheint so
gut wie sicher präsident minister und
ministerpräsidenten marien erklärten
heute schriftlich
als ein nato-mitglied würde finnland die
verteidigungsgemeinschaft stärken
finnland muss die nato-mitgliedschaft
unverzüglich beantragen wir hoffen dass
die nationalen schritte für die
entscheidung schnell innerhalb der
nächsten tage erfolgen
russlands präsident putin ließ gegen
krems sprecher paskov reagieren die nato
rückt weiter an uns heran natürlich
müssen wir die lage analysieren und
geeignete maßnahmen für unsere
sicherheit ergreifen
nach umfragen sind inzwischen drei
viertel der finnen für den nato-beitritt
das ding ist so wie sie denken nun ist
es richtig das zu tun angesichts der
lage in europa und in der ukraine
wir sind gut damit gefahren nicht in der
nato zu sein nein ich finde wir sollten
das nicht tun am montag wird das
parlament debattieren auch dort zeichnet
sich eine mehrheit für den nato-beitritt
ab egal wie regierung und parlament
gemeinsam entscheiden finnland erhöht
schon jetzt den verteidigungshaushalt um
zwei milliarden euro in den kommenden
vier jahren
da fragen wir direkt nach bei unseren
korrespondenten in moskau und brüssel
zuerst zu ihm florian hahn nach brüssel
wie schnell kann es denn gehen mit einem
nato-beitritt finnlands nato
verhältnisse unglaublich schnell während
sich die letzten nato erweiterungsrunden
richtung osten über jahre hinzogen
teilweise könnte es in diesem fall in
sechs bis acht monaten vollzogen sein
die beitrittsverhandlungen selbst so
hieß es hier heute könnten sogar an
einem einzigen tag beendet sein dann
aber müssten noch alle 30
nato-mitgliedsstaaten diese aufnahme in
ihren parlamenten oder in ihren
regierungen ratifizieren dass das ganze
so schnell gehen könnte liegt vor allem
daran dass man seit jahren mit den
beiden staaten finnland und auch
schweben eng zusammenarbeitet beide sind
ja auch mitglieder der europäischen
union
und dazu kommt dass die finisher armee
vor allem so gut ausgerüstet ist dass
die nato davon auch militärisch stark
profitieren würde also die nato empfängt
die beiden länder mit weit
ausgebreiteten armen und putin der die
nato eigentlich schwächen wollte hat das
genaue gegenteil erreicht christian
selben russland hat er bereits
angekündigt reagieren zu wollen wie denn
russland hat finnland in den letzten
jahren immer wieder genau vor diesem
schritt gewarnt und entsprechend
deutlich sind dann auch die kommentare
heute kann man sprecher peskow spricht
von einer deutlichen bedrohung und das
außenministerium wird in einem schreiben
sogar noch etwas deutlicher spricht von
konkreten
vergeltungsmaßnahmen
militärisch technischer natur was das
genau heißt weiß man nicht aber diese
äußerungen kennen wir schon die gab es
schon einmal von wladimir putin nämlich
vor dem start der militäroperationen
russland wirft der nato vor schweden und
finnland schon seit jahren in diese
rolle zu drängen und in das bündnis zu
drängen um die region militärisch
aufzurüsten und russlands zu bedrohen
und finnland sieht man jetzt an
vorderster front linie der nato was dann
durchaus auch als neue drohung zu
verstehen ist da kann sie beide nach
moskau und bronze über
die mögliche nato erweiterung können sie
mit sicherheits expertinnen und experten
diskutieren bei zdf heute live um 19.30
in der zdf- heute- app und auf unseren
social media kanälen
und auch was die energielieferungen
angeht spitzt sich der konflikt zu nach
sanktionen aus dem westen kürzt der
kreml jetzt die gaslieferungen nach
deutschland
betroffen die ehemaligen auslandstöchter
des gazprom konzerns
die bundesregierung hält die
auswirkungen aber für begrenzt derzeit
gibt es in drei haupt leitung von
russland nach deutschland
die jammerei pipeline durch die gerade
gar kein gas fließt die leitungen durch
die ukraine ist so hughes und
bruderschaft liefern rund 18 prozent gas
trotzdem 1 liefert das meiste gas rund
82% an seinem stern fast die neuen
entwicklungen zusammen
der kreml herrscher dreht am gashahn per
dekret entscheidet wladimir putin 31
unternehmen bekommen kein gas mehr aus
russland darunter gazprom germania die
firma steht seit april unter der
kontrolle der bundesnetzagentur gestern
nacht kam die sanktions nachricht sagt
robert habeck am morgen es halt also
dass die auseinandersetzung um energie
eine waffe ist und dass energie in einem
wirtschafts konflikt hat eingesetzt
werden kann am mittag der nächste
auftritt die botschaft gas aus russland
fließt weiter die neuen maßnahmen aus
moskau überschaubar wir haben
eine lieferung die nicht mehr erfolgt in
einer menge von 10 millionen kubikmeter
gas täglich aus russland auch das ist
eine menge die kompensierbar ist und die
unternehmen sind dabei das gas über
andere quellen zu beschaffen zehn
millionen kubikmeter gas pro tag das
wären aufs jahr gerechnet etwa drei
prozent der aktuellen russischen
lieferungen die müssen nun woanders
eingekauft werden vermutlich deutlich
teurer aber nötig auch um die
gasspeicher im land weiter auf zu finden
wenn man es ein speicher füllstand über
alle deutschen speicher von arne wort
christlich oder knapp 50 das ist kein
rekord zustand für diese zeit im jahr
das ist mittlerweile so ganz ordentlich
aber das heißt natürlich dass man noch
deutlich mehr mengen brauchen den winter
abgesichert zu sein weniger russisches
gas in den pipelines richtung westen der
krieg wird immer mehr auch ein kampf um
rohstofflieferungen und um die preise
täglich ja stündlich werde die gas lage
in deutschland beobachtet heißt es heute
in berlin
in berlin war heute der ukrainische
aussenminister clever zu besuch er sieht
das deutsch ukrainische verhältnisse
inzwischen auf einem guten weg bei
waffenlieferungen und russland
sanktionen bewege sich die
bundesregierung sagte kleber nach einem
treffen mit spd chef klingen weil und
fraktionschef mütze nicht allerdings
müssten jetzt die richtigen
entscheidungen getroffen werden die
ukraine hatte deutschland lange
vorgeworfen zu zögerlich gegen russland
vorzugehen
und ein interview mit dem ukrainischen
außenminister haben wir im heute-journal
ab 21 uhr 40 schauen wir jetzt direkt in
die ukraine in der region rund um die
stark umkämpfte million stadtarchiv von
dort meldet die ukrainische armee in den
vergangenen tagen dass sie gebiete
zurückerobert hätte und die russischen
besatzer nach und nach zurück bringen
würde unsere zdf reporterin katrin
eigendorf für heute in einem vorort
nordöstlich von hf inside ifa unterwegs
um sich ein bild von der lage dort zu
verschaffen
wir sind nahe der frontlinie in einem
außenbezirk von hartz iv die soldaten
nehmen uns mit in ihre stellung wir
dürfen nicht zeigen wo genau wir uns
befinden das könnte sie gefährden in
einem keller haben sie ihren
unterschlupf nach wochenlangen kämpfen
ist es ihnen gelungen die russischen
truppen zurückzudrängen dörfer im norden
und osten von tief zu befreien
wie kann man das erklären was ist
passiert
ich denke in erster linie ist das mit
hilfe des westens gelungen waffen wir
hatten keine waffen jetzt kommen die
lieferungen nur deswegen
es hat lange gedauert bis der westen
ihnen waffen geliefert hat nun hoffen
sie auf weitere unterstützung die
soldaten hier gehören zur ukrainischen
territorialverteidigung sie haben hier
die russische armee erfolgreich
zurückgeschlagen das führen sie vor
allem darauf zurück dass sie aus dem
westen waffen bekommen haben igor ist
gerade 31 jahre alt geworden früher
handelte er mit handys am 24 februar hat
er sich entschieden für sein land zu
kämpfen
wir sind wie eine familie
es gibt keinen rückwärtsgang wir schauen
nicht zurück
schauen nach vorne wir wissen unsere
aufgabe ist es unsere familie zu
schützen
was denken sie über die russen die bis
vor kurzem noch ihre nachbarn waren die
grenze ist nur wenige kilometer entfernt
das sind keine menschen sie haben keine
strategie sie sind nur kanonenfutter
sie kommen und töten menschen die nichts
getan haben
rund um das ganze ausmaß der zerstörung
wohnhäuser in die die menschen nicht
zurückkommen können es wird lange dauern
das wieder aufzubauen
so viel von unserer reporterin aus der
region aktiv unterdessen soll es weiter
schwere gefechte im süden wie auch im
osten des landes gegeben haben und die
ukraine meldet weitere angriffe auf das
umkämpfte asaf stahlwerk in mariupol in
dem sich noch rund 1000 soldaten
aufhielten sie sollen gegen russische
kriegsgefangene ausgetauscht werden so
ein vorschlag aus kiel
wir wechseln das thema das
entlastungspaket des bundes zur
abfederung der finanziellen folgen des
ukraine krieges kommt der bundestag hat
am abend zugestimmt
unter anderem wird der grundfreibetrag
rückwirkend zum ersten januar um 363
euro angehoben die pendlerpauschale wird
ab dem 21 kilometer bereits für dieses
jahr um drei cent erhöht außerdem
beschlossen eine sogenannte energie
pauschale in höhe von 300 euro für alle
einkommensteuerpflichtigen und ein
einmaliger kinderbonus von 100 euro pro
kind
das alles kostet da wurde heute genau
auf diesen termin geschaut die
steuerschätzung dabei kam heraus dass
bund länder und kommunen in diesem jahr
sogar 40,4 milliarden euro mehr
einnehmen werden als noch im november
erwartet
grund für euphorie finanzminister
christian lindner schüttelt den kopf die
details von henriette de maizière
trotz ukraine krieg und abflauender
konjunktur lage kann der staat mit
höheren steuereinnahmen rechnen ein
grund dafür die inflation steigen die
preise im inland profitiert der staat
die steuer erwartung für bund länder und
kommunen für 2022 beträgt 8 189
milliarden euro das sind 40 milliarden
mehr als im vergangenen november
geschätzt und die zahlen steigen stetig
ab 2026 sogar über die grenze von einer
billion doch der finanzminister bremst
heute die euphorie diese steuerschätzung
kommt in einer phase ja sehr hoher
wirtschaftlicher unsicherheit wir kennen
die ökonomischen konsequenzen des
krieges in der ukraine noch nichts wir
wissen nicht welche auswirkungen die
pandemie auf die lieferketten etwa aus
china hat
außerdem seien die mehreinnahmen des
bundes schon wieder aufgebraucht durch
die jüngst beschlossenen
entlastungsmaßnahmen dennoch die
opposition fordert noch mehr glaube wir
brauchen ein riesiges entlastungspaket
und da ist die regierung jetzt
aufgefordert etwas zu tun wir werden die
regierung dazu vorschläge machen
bundesfinanzminister lindner sieht
keinen spielraum für zusätzliche
ausgaben er will ab 2023 die
schuldenbremse wieder einhalten
die polizei in essen hat möglicherweise
einen rechten anschlag verhindert in der
wohnung eines schülers entdeckten
fahnder waffen und material für mehrere
sprengsätze offenbar hatte der
16-jährige angriffe auf zwei schulen
geplant es wurden bei ihm rassistische
und rechtsextreme schriften gefunden
ralph goldmann berichtet
das spezialeinsatzkommando kam um kurz
vor halb fünf und nahm den 16-jährigen
im kinderzimmer der elterlichen wohnung
fest die ermittler fanden eine
selbstgebaute schusswaffe eine armbrust
präparierte rohre und zusammengemischten
explosivstoffe sagte landesinnenminister
herbert reul möglicherweise hat die nrw
polizei heute ein alptraum verhindert
der tatverdächtige hat über material
verfügt das offensichtlich über den bau
von bomben vorgesehen und auch
vorbereitet war sind fähige sprengsätze
seien aber nicht darunter die ermittler
entdeckten außerdem ss runen und
rechtsextreme antisemitische und
antimuslimische schriftstücke darin habe
sich der 16 jährige in einer art
hilferuf auch verzweifelt geäußert es
gebe hinweise auf massive psychische
probleme so der innenminister
zu diesen 16 jährigen tatverdächtigen
hat uns ein hinweisgeber geführt der
tatverdächtige hatte diesen diesem
hinweisgeber erzählt er wolle bomben in
seiner schule platzieren deshalb waren
die aktuelle und die ehemalige schule
des tatverdächtigen am morgen
vorsorglich geschlossen geblieben
sprengsätze von die polizei dort nicht
gegen den 16 jährigen ermittelt jetzt
die generalstaatsanwaltschaft düsseldorf
wegen des verdachts der vorbereitung
einer schweren staatsgefährdenden
gewalttat
zum ersten mal seit beginn der korona
pandemie hat nordkorea offiziell
infektionen bestätigt bei tests in der
hauptstadt pjöngjang sei eine omi konsum
variante nachgewiesen worden berichten
staatsmedien machthaber kim jong il nun
landesweit einen harten locker und
verhängen das abgeschottete nordkorea
hatte bislang keinen einzigen corona
fall gemeldet daran gab es jedoch schon
länger zweifel
wie fotografiert man ein objekt das von
natur aus unsichtbar ist mit diesen
fragen beschäftigen sich astronomen und
astronomen wenn sie über schwarze löcher
reden solch ein schwarzes loch gibt es
auch in unserer milchstraße und das hat
jetzt ein internationales team von
forschenden erstmals fotografiert wie
man das macht das erklärt enkeln klinge
es war ein streng gehütetes geheimnis
erstmals präsentieren wissenschaftler
zeitgleich in verschiedenen städten der
welt ein bild des schwarzen lochs im
herzen der milchstraße unserer galaxie
rund 27.000 lichtjahre von der erde
entfernt eine sensation
schwarze löcher spielen eine ganz
wichtige rolle weil wir mittlerweile
überzeugt sind dass ein solches
supermassives schwarzes loch schwarzes
loch wie in unserer oder dieser
entfernten galaxie tatsächlich in allen
galaxien diesen milliarden galaxien im
universum
vorhanden sind auch sitzen schwarze
löcher sind am rande der menschlichen
vorstellungskraft und möglicherweise ein
schlüssel zur entstehung des universums
sie verschlingen durch ihre hohe
anziehungskraft alles in ihrer umgebung
sogar licht sichtbar ist nur die heiße
materie die vom loch angezogen wird
gelungen ist die spektakuläre aufnahme
durch das event horizon teleskop ein
zusammenschluss von acht radioteleskopen
auf vier kontinenten wenn man den
münchner biergarten sitzt dann kann man
mit diesem teleskop die blasen im schaum
eines bierglases in new york sehen also
besser kann man nicht beobachten vor
drei jahren gelang das allererste bild
eines schwarzen lochs überhaupt in einer
anderen galaxie die bilder ähneln sich
und bestätigen auch albert einstein und
seine relativitätstheorie
er hatte bereits vor mehr als 100 jahren
die existenz von schwarzen löchern
vorausgesagt
so kaufte der erde johannes north texas
wäre turnier in rom
das viertelfinale geschafft und er wird
von runde zu runde besser heute setzte
sich der olympiasieger aus hamburg ging
alex den me nor aus australien durch mit
62 37 zu 6
konzentriert und kraftvoll beginnt
alexander zverev gegen den australier
gelingen ihm im ersten satz zwei breaks
es sieht nach einem durchmarsch aus
punkt zum 6 2 3 doch in durchgang zwei
ein rückfall in alte fehler es wäre es
muss in den tie break und das zittern
beginnt sein gegner deminor gegen den er
in sechs partien fünfmal gewann kann die
schwächen des weltranglistendritten
jedoch nicht nutzen mit risiko und mit
erfolg spiels wäre von den stop zum
matchgewinn
6 3 und 7 6 fazit licht und schatten bei
swift die form für seinen ersten
turniersieg in diesem jahr hat er noch
nicht
[Applaus]
zur handball champions league da steht
flensburg handewitt vor dem aus die sg
unterlag zuhause im viertelfinal
hinspiel gegen titelverteidiger
barcelona mit 29 zu 33 beste karten hat
dagegen der deutsche rekordmeister aus
kiel der thw holte bei paris st germain
ein starkes 30 30 unentschieden bester
werfer bei den kielern der norwegers
anders sah russen mit sechs treffern
einer davon mit augenmaß für das leere
gegnerische
inter mailand ist italienischer
pokalsieger dank des doppelpacks von ex
bundesliga profi ivan pejic in der
verlängerung gegen juventus turin sorgte
der kroate für den 4 2 erfolg
er ist ohne frage der mann der partie 2
2 steht es nach der regulären spielzeit
david in der verlängerung der
niederländer gewicht den niederländer de
frei elfmeter ivan pejcic tritt an
verwandelt
das sei aber eine herausragende
schusstechnik verfügt städter kurz
darauf noch einmal unter beweis ein
herrlicher treffer zum 4 2 endstand
inter mailand ist es bereits der achte
pokalsieg und auch in der meisterschaft
haben sie noch chancen auf den titel
und erstmals übrigens seit 2011 das juve
wieder eine saison ganz ohne titelgewinn
enttäuscht danke norbert
teils unwetterartige gewitter ziehen
heute nacht im süden durch wo genau das
zeigt ihnen gleich ist intelli um 21 40
gibt es das heute journal mit marietta
slomka schönen abend noch
[Musik]
sogenannte und herzlich willkommen zum
wetter in den nächsten stunden am abend
und in der nacht gibt es kräftige
schauer und gewitter
das liegt an dieser kaltfront die hier
an den alpen entlang schleift ja und in
der nacht werden sich also diese
gewitter fortsetzen heftig können die
ausfallen mit hagel sturmböen und
starkregen und das am alpenrand bis etwa
richtung bayern im südosten ansonsten
ganz im norden regen dazwischen lockert
teilweise auf und die sterne zeigen sich
bei tiefsten werten im norden im
einstelligen bereich und zwölf grad
ausnahme an der nordsee sonst im süden
deutlich milder bei 12 bis 16 grad
morgen tagesverlauf an den alpen weitere
schauer und gewitter bis richtung
bayerischer wald und ganz im norden
ebenfalls schauer der zwischen teilweise
sonnenschein und nur harmlose bewölkung
bei höchsten temperaturen von 15 bis 16
grad ganz im norden deutschlands und bis
25 grad im südwesten die nächsten tage
am samstag ist es trocken bis 27 grad
sonntag ebenfalls viel sonnenschein bis
29 und montag teilweise heftige gewitter
ein schöner abend